chaque jour que le temps fait la nature
poursuit son oeuvre est dans un endroit
comme si l'os
le tableau est splendide
venus de toute l'île ses copines se
retrouvent entre elles pour cette visite
des trois salazes organisée dans le
cadre de la fête de la nature plancoët à
la fin d'un côté française en usage
externe cutanée contre l'acné mes
problèmes de peau on va dire notamment à
bakou l'abandonnèrent alors faire une
découverte de la faune et de la flore
des sentiers ajoutez à cela évidemment
un petit bout d'histoire c'est une
petite oasis se percher sur le col du
taïbit 8 ou voilà où nous fait découvrir
les gens à travers les tisanes et aussi
la faune et la flore lille est c'est à
dire les plantes les oiseaux l'histoire
du site
donc c'est important pour nous de
participer à cette fête justement pour
faire découvrir les gens ces patrimoines
où l'association
on a été créé en 98 on travaille pas
avec le départ pour le département
donc on essaye de remettre en valeur
lille est qui avait déjà fait une
dizaine de familles qui habitent et vous
allez voir où vous trouvez le filao et
altice et l'acacia habitées de quoi
créer un il est atypique plein d'espacé
exotiques tels que le pommier cerisier
ou encore châtaignier ici elles sont
toutes les bienvenus il ya plein
d'endroits qu'on ne connaît pas et qu'on
n'ose pas y aller
et là vraiment avec un guide c'est super
génial jusque jusque dimanche et jusqu'à
marla et puis après on va dormir à roche
plate t on
on va sortir au maïdo le thème de fait
de la nature c'est l'homme la passion
pour la nature est ce que les aides dans
cette phase-là de trois jours en
immersion votre copine dans mafate
ah bah oui complètement la nature
pas de voiture les jambes pour se
déplacer la bcb on est à quelques on est
content et satisfait de notre sortie
aujourd'hui post and any à 22 22 sites
ouverts pour mon public et 60
manifestations visites guidées des
thématiques et pourquoi sa monnaie ou
pourquoi parce que les gens sont plus en
plus passionné par l'environnement sont
plus intéressés par leur environnement
je pense que la marge et des gens a pris
conscience que nos patrimoines
importants
tous les ans le département investit 10
millions d'euros pour cent mille
hectares de forêt ces dixièmes
rencontres permettent ainsi de rendre
visibles les liens avec ces associations
des scènes de vie en lien avec la nature
plein d'enseignements loin du quotidien
de beaucoup de réunionnais qu'on préfet
là je suis en train de traire
le cabri pour faire du fromage
comment tu vas pas trop mal de corps à
corps en rajouter avec romain delattre
et ouais
et après on va faire chauffer on va
récupérer le petit cahier et après on
fait filtrer locale qui considère un
petit maire a présenté trois petits
cahiers et après le fromage avec des
réflexions qui se termine autour du feu
et d'un bon cari idéal pour refaire le
monde